I'm not like you be for different
different different different
differentiate different differently what
I'm thinking is so superior and when now
it is so positive and my logic as always
until it clashes with the mentality
which is down here and I'm both there
I'm even saw ha I can see more see
father knew and you're looking at mrs.
Ali don't do it honey please down why
you're hurt and you want a job making 60
70 pounds a week this day never been out
of the country not known in his own
neighborhood Ali don't do it but I'm in
such a high level until I don't think
like you I'm not like you
I'm not say you a mean on your person
but you Bernard
do you know why they say that I race for
the best possible reason so they have
fear and they aware it looks looks
dangerous to them that's right not
really they're dangerous to me how do
you feel when people copy you know I'm
not happy that means I'm success okay
yeah it also pushes you right and also
pushing it I want a different life what
I do in a comedy that your comedy we're
not doing a action they do a action okay
how cannot different okay I do dangerous
stuff nobody copy me definitely not one
scrap everything okay check it you do
you do that then I just continue doing
that dangerous stunts individuality and
just appreciating like the way I think
in the way I feel and and having you
know letting that have some value and
Worth and and and depending on that so
you know what if everybody else is you
know what was what is the four or five
mmm y'all got like twenty nine million
highways are here yes sir right take a
different route if everything y'all got
traffic there that isn't that what you
guys do
yeah you get off on the next X and you
go somewhere else you rather sit in the
traffic with a stoplight than to be on
the 405 trapped right I'm saying and I
think that like individuality is a is a
wonderful thing is the reason why Drake
is so good it's the reason why Lord is
so good and you know it's the reason why
you know the west coast own piloted
created on future and Kendrick Lamar
like these are all like none of those
guys sound alike yet instill they're all
out at the same time right doing there
you know prospective things right so
it's betting on yourself and betting on
your difference and appreciating the
rarity of how you think you know
I wanted to excel my game and isolate my
game from everybody else said I was more
than just you know a few dimensional
even when it came to Magic Johnson I
mean Magic Johnson was your crowd
pleaser he was a good offensive player
he was a great motivator you know
average defensive player and I want to
change that one taking another step I
want to do all those things you know
that it could separate me from Magic
Johnson you know I'm not saying he
wasn't great he still is great but we're
great in our own different way you know
and that was motivational for me you
know and to this day still is I'm saying
this is the time more than ever that you
want to begin to inoculate yourself with
positive words coming to conventions
showing up on meetings being on the
calls to make yourself unstoppable to
get out of your mind the polluting
negative thoughts that's causing most
people to go through life being stuck
because they are volunteer victims
somebody said that many people died age
25 and don't get buried until they're at
65 because they got so much garbage in
their minds you are here because you've
got a clear vision of what you want and
where you're going give yourselves a
round of applause come on bring energy
level
yes yes you want more you want more
you're different you're different than
everybody else don't worry if they don't
get it don't try and convince people to
do this business a person convinced
against their will is of the same
opinion still you are not like everybody
else you can walk outside and find
pigeons but if you're looking for Eagles
it's going to take you a minute
you are different it's lonely at the top
how many of you know it's lonely at the
top raise your hands it's lonely at the
top but you eat better that's what I'm
talking about you're different
one great entrepreneur said I choose not
to be a common man it's my right to be
uncommon if I can I'll seek opportunity
not security I do not wish to be a kept
citizen humbled and oh by having the
state look after me I want to take the
calculated risk to dream and to bill to
fail and to succeed I refuse to live
from hand to mouth I prefer the
challenges of life to the guaranteed
existence the thrill of fulfillment to
the still calm of utopia I will never
cower before a master nor been to any
threat it's my heritage to stand erect
proud and unafraid the face the world
boldly and say this I have done you
showed up because you're building a
business that you can stand and say I
did this I did this
this is my dream give yourselves a round
of applause
yes yes yes
yes I've been working I've been in
business for 69 years since I was 12 and
every time
well after the first dozen or so
businesses I realized that the only way
to get ahead was to do things different
definitely than the way it was being
done and then I came to learn which I
finally learned at my ripe young age
that if you do things differently
success will follow you like your shadow
and you can't get rid of it so that's
what I did
so people doubted me because people just
didn't do what I what I would do
it's a matter of tainted finding out
what it is that an industry does and
identify the opportunity to as to how to
do it differently and then being enough
of a risk-taker to actually do it
differently so people doubted me because
nobody thought of doing it the way that
I did and nobody had the they didn't
have the they were satisfied with the
status quo and I've never satisfied with
the status quo let's not get stuck on
one thing this lets you know rap music
is about diversity like if you know you
got on those Nikes i'ma just write you
know dunks and it's all about everyone
contribution you know you had before you
had tried Ice Cube Public Enemy at the
same time as did you - underground was
just so many different I had every album
you know it was all different types of
sounds and approaches but it was still
great music I'm not just you know
auto-tune is bad you know their songs
that have auto-tune that I love but when
everyone jumps on this bandwagon and
everyone make tribes to make the same
exact record I mean I heard that record
from t-pain I liked it I want to hit a
hundred times from a hundred different
artists like I want to hear different
stuff is the most extraordinary
businesses in the world are focused on
finding
a better way there what I call best way
companies they're constantly trying to
find a better way to do what to do what
they do to do what to differentiate
themselves from everybody else
how by giving the customer the sense of
control in our business that they don't
have anyplace else the clean workings of
Disneyland you know you ask people what
do you remember about the park and what
they all say is it's clean now think
about it they don't talk about Mickey
they don't talk about Pluto they don't
talk about done they say it's clean now
why in the world would that matter to
people because everyplace else is so
dirty
how did walk do that every night at
Disneyland they steam clean the entire
park and they've been doing that in
Anaheim for over 35 years think about
that to do what to create this sense of
order in the mind of the consumer which
instantly differentiates them from
everybody else every place else is dirty
our place is not I was in Tokyo with one
of the businessmen from India and when I
was talking to my I realized that
acquisition is a way to grow I realized
that life is very short and if you have
to really do something you have to do
very quickly if you have to grow we have
to do something differently than what
everyone else has been doing so I
started thinking that if I start
building a steel plant it would take
years and how many steel plants how many
companies you can build and if I have to
succeed in my life I have to find a
formula which is different and which
keeps me ahead of my competition and my
colleagues that's how I thought that we
should acquire companies merge
consolidate them reduce the cost make
them very efficient
and it became like a turn around became
a science I would say that yeah it sort
of there's science or art it is a mix of
science and art because every company
has a different issue it's not that
there is a formula which you apply eye
on everyone yeah it is not as to all
this water here but the pattern you
establish this pattern and applied it in
different countries different markets
yes and that was the genesis of your
empire yes I would say the overarching
and key thing that really binds the
group together is the idea of not just
playing the game but changing it for
good I think Richard embodies the
principles better than anyone I've ever
worked with than anybody that I know
because he's very focused on business on
starting new businesses on making sure
that you've got the right people in the
businesses but also on doing things
differently and really changing the game
and I think that it's the combination of
those that sits in apart is the great
entrepreneur of his generation thank you
guys so much for watching I'd love to
know how you are different in your
business and what being different means
to you I think for me it's about
bringing yourself fully to the company I
think it's easy for people to if you're
a financial adviser or software engineer
or whatever company you're starting to
be the typical software engineer or
financial adviser like everybody else
and when you're different is when you're
more yourself and bringing your other
interests to make it a business that
only you can do I think that's where the
real power is but I'm really curious to
find out how you are different how you
bring yourself to your business as well
as which of the clips that you saw here
is the most interesting inspiring to you
going to have the biggest impact on your
life leaving the comments below
I'm going to join the discussion thank
you so much for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon